- Man, this place looks so cool.
- I know, it's a huge
studio. We lucked out.
- Yeah, you did. I mean,
- Yeah. It's like a really-
- they did probably.
- It's home. It's home.
So wait, I, I heard that being here
is a little bit of revenge
for you. So, how so?
- Okay. So when I was young-
(laughing)
- I love this story all ready.
- That was this girl. I was
kind of into her and I was-
I used to listen to
death metal at the time.
- Okay.
- And so she was like,
oh my God, there's this
woman Kelly Clarkson.
She's like so good at
singing. I love her music.
- I love her already.
- I was like, oh my God.
I love Kelly Clarkson. I
didn't know at that time.
- You didn't even know me.
- So I ended up using you
a little bit at that moment.
(laughing)
Didn't work out for us.
- Okay. Okay.
- But I like your music a lot.
So you stuck with me.
So right now is a really funny time.
Cause yeah, so if you're out there-
- Look at me now, look at me now.
(clapping and laughing)
That's amazing. Rub it in.